what's up everybody
welcome back to cosmic wonder i'm your
host lauren i just walked out of the tlc
chinese theater just watched thor loving
thunder my man e-man right here you guys
check him out chris is doing his own
reaction in the back right now but
okay so going into thor loving thunder
thor is one of my ultimate thor's my
ultimate favorite character you can see
the picture right here
thor is my ultimate favorite character
so
i had pretty high hopes for this one and
uh i
there's so much to this movie and
there's a lot of really important parts
to this movie important parts and uh oh
man post credit scenes uh
one post credit scene in particular is
super super cool everyone's gonna
everyone's gonna be really excited about
this post-credits scene uh oh my gosh it
was funny
i laughed i cried
christian bale is
phenomenal
phenomenal like if you were worried
about gordon butcher
or christopher's portrayal of him or how
he looks just throw that away because
christian bale is truly amazing at score
the god butcher like he crushed it and
when people were saying like he might be
the best marvel villain ever
i mean that's a debate now which is a
really big thing to say because
his his portrayal of
gor the god butcher like awesome villain
awesome villain loved him as the villain
loved how he was like it i won't say
much because it's just a reaction but uh
christian bill's goal of the god butcher
was amazing chris hemsworth crushed it
as thor again natalie portman amazing
tessa thompson amaze like everyone was
amazing
in this movie the pacing was great
there's some amazing scenes like truly
amazing scenes and uh there's some
really heavy parts as far as like
importance to the mcu and as far as like
connectivity in the mcu
huge parts
huge
huge hearts so
go watch the 11 thunder as soon as you
can also i'll be posting a longer kind
of reaction gathering my thoughts more
in like a few hours so stay on the
lookout for that probably around like 6
a.m pacific time so i i love the movie i
thought it was great fantastic i can't
wait to watch it again and wrap my head
around it a little bit more uh it's not
what you think in some parts which is
kind of cool
um but yeah it's amazing so i'll check
you all next time love you all in every
universe